de damas à québec des destins qui se
sont croisés
ce déni venice ac et de christiane
gagnon à l'automne 2010 est christiane
gagnon accepte d'héberger une jeune
syrienne qui vient d'être acceptée au
baccalauréat en pharmacie à l'université
laval
quand j'ai dit ce que j'ai vu l'une
venait de la série mois pour moi la
série ça sonnait quelque chose en moi
les roches de susano propriétaire est un
syrien ayant aussi voyager en syrie dans
les années 80
madame gagnon voulait aider la jeune
femme forcés de vivre un deuxième
déracinement j'avais déjà quitté mon
pays et puis c'était une autre fois
d'équipé mes parents il y avait des
moments où je voulais qu'on soit
abandonnée mais elle m'a toujours
encouragé de continuer c'est le 12
décembre 2015
lors du premier vol nolisé par le
gouvernement canadien pour amener des
milliers de réfugiés syriens montréal
que nous avions rencontré ni vis ni sac
de 10 mois à peine vous ne parliez pas
un bout de phrase c'est bien ça il était
venu accueillir un cousin un autre
membre de la famille parrainée par son
oncle bas c'est miss à l'entrepreneur
s'est ainsi porté garant de ses trois
frères et de leurs familles respectives
qui fuyaient la guerre en syrie arrivé
seul au canada il ya quinze ans il est
maintenant bien entouré au total c'est
presque vingt deux personnes
c'est eux et ils ont fait un effort là
avec la francisation peu après ils ont
commencé à travailler tout le monde est
ni lait ni sac reste très proche de ses
parents et de ses frères qui sont à
montréal
pour tous c'est une nouvelle vie j'étais
dans la dernière même pharmacie oui et
moment que justin 1 pour être pharmacien
mais si je dois je pensais le faire en
trois ans peut-être quand on arrivait
mais j'ai pris une chose à la fois quand
on dit puis c'est ça je vais finir vous
bientôt
j'ai vraiment en 3e année elle fait
présentement un stage à l'hôtel dieu de
lévis mais ni vinh aura aussi appris
beaucoup de choses sur le québec en
passant sa première année chez
christiane gagnon a le études en cours
d'histoire avec moi à la crise d'octobre
et puis je faisais écouter lee simmons
j'avais compte chaque jour une heure
d'histoire puis une heure de français
c'est qu'on découvre vraiment mais à la
maison c'était vraiment une belle
rencontre je me sens vraiment chanceuse
d'avoir tout ce genre autour de moi je
pensais que c'était les ennemis reine de
palmyre qui arrivait chez nous ici à
nourrice despatie radio canada québec